top chef ou un nouveau numéro de top
chef qui a cartonné ils sont une
nouvelle fois arrivé en tête des
audiences
numéro 1 dans quel six numéros de tf1
numéro 3 france 2 numéro 4 le monde de
jamie et et sur arte et france
magnifique magnifique film magnifique
film franz bien sûr j'attends noir et
blanc j'adore ce film oui bah c'est bon
c'est bon l'émission est un succès mais
on se demande si l'émission n'a pas dû
mal à se renouveler pourquoi puisque eux
il devait défier une fois de plus
philippe etchebest
ça fait 150 points qui le film est si
grosse fatigue et me ce qui nous regarde
notre adversaire du jour
le voici chef ce soir direction bordeaux
et la table tout étoile et de philippe
etchebest
bonjour c'est à domicile que le chef a
décidé d'affronter des candidats ce soir
la compétition reprend de plus belle
avec pour commencer qui peut battre
philippe etchebest an plus tôt
c'est le grand retour d'une épreuve
désormais mythique et incontournable qui
peut battre philippe etchebest château
quelle surprise ouais et qui peut battre
philippe et tu restes là c'était encore
à chaque fois ils disent au bout des
doigts par quelqu'un le pauvre toujours
et sortent philippe etchebest philippe
etchebest y en a marre symbole il a même
pas le temps d'aller chez le coiffeur
sud ah oui il définit des who et oui les
missions du mal à se renouveler pourquoi
parce qu'en france il ya tellement de
chef cuisinier il pourrait faire un
roulement jeu permettra aux français de
découvrir tous ces grands chefs qui en
ce moment d'ailleurs sans la maison
merci votre deuxième intervention était
mieux que la première
géraldine maillet et surtout pas en fait
on voit cette épreuve mythique ouais
c'est vrai vasic on veut les
fondamentaux on veut voir et chez m
alors évidemment il ya des nouvelles
recettes ya des nouveaux candidats bien
c'est tout le reste c est chez mais
c'est comme si on dit bon vu cyril
hanouna sûreté pmp face à na aucun sens
et basique je le comprendrais une
attention à prendre est tombé après ce
qu'a dit sarah frézouls le comprendre
non mais ça mais si je vous le dise même
lit oui bon c'est normal qu'ils
s'appuient sur philippe etchebest est la
star du programme
quant au bout de 12 saisons vous arrivez
encore à faire 3 millions de sur m6
d'être leader franchement c'est que
l'émission n'est pas fatigué moi j'ai
revu les émissions de taupe elle est ma
fatigue déjà vu dans l'émission top chef
pour 2011 ya dix ans avait rien à voir
il y avait pas les mêmes chefs pas les
mêmes épreuves ils ont changé la
réalisation et c'est donc non
franchement bravo
j'eus irin la concurrence excuse-moi
fait pas non plus à ses attentes
si on regarde pas mais qu'est ce que
c'est c'est pas ou n'ont plus rien en
phase i télé fin ils sont étonnants le
trooper ce n'est fait nous sur ces 8 on
a fait 791 téléspectateurs avec voilà le
monde de demi 1 millions 6 35 millions
forêt bois mais avec la on est quand
même au couvre-feu c'est là que les gens
ils sont tous ces pourris sont ils ont
en tout cas ils sont pas se relayer dans
l'hymne national partout ils sont
partout et j'aurais sont partout ils ont
le droit d'être où ils veulent et vous
emmerde ces voix-là j'hibernais bien sûr
qu'ils ont du mal à se renouveler à tel
point qu'elle baisse n'est plus seul
il lui met paul pairet les deux c'est
toi c'est totalement sécurisé il fait
semblant d'avoir du mal avec ces justes
ans il on voit que c'est faux ça sonne
faux du début à la fin
franchement il faut qu'ils changent de
registre on n'en peut plus des données
alors pour moi philippe etchebest c'est
le
meyer et les petits gestes mais je pense
que vraiment c'est le meilleur il manque
des émissions même avec huit ans conclut
majordome forte et moi tu vois toujours
dit vous voit toute la journée h24 vous
avez 30 ses émissions sur ces vies nous
regarde
donc moi je pense qu'être bien et gilles
verdez voulu confirmerai ça c'est sûr
qu'on la verra pas dans mes émissions
ça c'est sûr le shérif dans cette
émission normalement on est habitué à
voir des plats gastronomiques et hier
ils ont lâché la rampe
il ya une candidate elle nous a fait une
tête comme ça parce qu'elle préparait
quoi des eaux plat sachez le c'est mon
club préféré très dur à faire j'adore
les hopla oui lèverait durera très dur à
faire c'est plus dur que de refaire ça
boume absolument c'est pourquoi pas
surtout que sa cuisse trail c'est vrai
c'est très dur à faire lagarde ferait un
matin 40 ans dormir enfin c'est vrai sa
mère départ je vous crois qu il trouve
maintenant sous quelle forme et mettre
là
[Musique]
neuf mois je fous une poêle là dans les
normes barbeuk et je ne suis europe là
et on fait juste un joli et ça c'est pas
mal ça
[Musique]
évacué vraiment tout doucement
alors cela traînait en prison
bravo chloé saison ont l'air
parfaitement cuits à la baisse et ouais
c'est vrai c'est quoi ta spécialité
delphine boîte à idées qu une spécialité
ces nourritures du monde sait qu'avec
des mots caouette avec du led to walk
away we go way des pâtes ou du riz et
puis des légumes ouais bah écoutez mon
projet il doit pas qui fait tous les
jours
spécialité vous berne à montescot votre
vitalité culinaire alors c'est marrant
que vous parliez des yeux parce que
justement c'est ce que j'ai mangé à midi
c'est intéressant puisque dans la foulée
[Rires]
spaghetti on savait vous savez rien
faire pour ça que je suis là les
spaghettis carbonara tout ça voyez ça
chez vous ça m'intéresse pas du tout la
cuisine je n'ai pas arrêté de crier
comme ça les ouvertures le q auriez-vous
suis l'homme
non je n'aime pas faire la cuisine je
veux qu'on me la fasse où est alors
tomate mozzarella ils devenus fous je
vous dis tomate mozzarella spécialités
ses spécialités sait faire que ça j'ai
fait chauffer une fois la plaque ça a
pris change est arrivé je sais pas chez
un copain ça je suis nul je fais une
blind revivre ces gosses j'en étais
nicolas pernikoff où nous bouclons la
baci parmentier j'adore lui et quand il
doit avoir des amis genre comme moi et
genre un peu il offert d'en regarder ce
que nous a apporté
je voulais un couscous donc je vous
ferai des saint jacques
cyril sacre ouverte que les plages il
[Rires]
nous a écoutés avec cyril et mounir on a
mangé un repas chine
on sait comment fait le couscous le
couscous la saumure pas très compliqué
quand même c'est justement avec avec les
mains directement ah oui c'est vrai ça
donc voilà rouler paquet pied moi on va
écouter ses caissettes satine tu
cuisines temps ma chérie assénant pas du
tout moi la dernière fois que j'ai fait
des pâtes j'ai déclenché l'alarmé
incendie
c'est à ça mais raté mais tu vas nous
foutent le feu